welcome to this video Alonzo Mosely ok
so let's see what we get symmetrical
English ok yeah I'm going before I
always like to play d4 myself down not
allowed like to play the fiber possible
to be six really
hmm they normally play Bishop e7 in this
kind of move in this kind of position
we should have four maybe is going t
five I guess
see if I've Bishop d7 95 is this good
it's very slow okay useless time spent
yeah but okay if I see a move that
strikes me as being and strikes me as
being somewhat on in the opening I
really try to to punish that and this
should be six struck me as being a bit a
bit unknown uncommon sometimes really
really get something but not here I
guess okay if it goes d4 i have night a
four and we'll get the bishops I guess
there should be six Bishop g5 it's not
working YouTube mission f2 unfortunately
otherwise it would be really nice to get
the pin into work maybe it should be 694
though yeah let's do that try to grab
this Bishop episode I'm going to snatch
that oh he's allowing but should be
three here with a temple deform that if
I look the eight though okay hmm that's
really annoying
rooty 8
I can play Bishop see 6b 6b form hmm it
looks it looks strange okay if I castle
and he goes deform that's not great
hmm
and I don't like that if he gets in
deform okay maybe I should have gone
Bishop g5 if I don't I don't really know
very very tricky now it's going to four
of course and my my night there I have
to move it again really lost lots of
time here
you felt I I need to move my bishop so
sometimes at some time cool not great
not great this is an understatement okay
let's see if I can disturb him here if
it takes me to ok not much to do about
it
really that's strange move might be
three rupee one traps the night did I
overlooked something here I don't don't
quite get it
hmm somehow catching up in this game I
guess and that I was thinking that this
might be what he wants to do okay if I
take f six years to take with the Jeep
on that's still right I think it's still
okay and now he too is under under some
pressure the night really looks entirely
wrong he cannot take it too that's good
Jake be three at the end
NEX go here opening up the diagonal
maybe a Quincy two night at five as an
idea okay let's go here now maybe d3 is
possible yeah hmm yeah stumbling into
some stupid tactic again
yeah okay
you
Quincy to was immensely stupid and
completely unnecessary here self trapped
his night on be three years old it can
never ever be good for black and I give
them the game I'm warning with this
nonsense
it doesn't really matter I could also
resign but I have to punish myself a
little bit with continuing
what are you doing jack at least I've
got a night if you are in shooting mode
or swindling mode would be the better
term it's always good to have a night
no come on but white resigns what a
downright stupid game he really just
gives me the game after i miss play the
opening 9 a-5 what kind of stuff is that
yeah and now I'm really screwing this up
royally Quincy too it's just just
amazingly stupid I mean d3 is kind of
his only ID am and and I run right into
that and after some normal move here
something like this I mean what is blank
doing now the only thing that he can do
with some maybe d3 if UD 3 is not
working right here he is just downright
lost ya with 92 f 4 with a strap night
down so it has to go d 3 this is
probably okay right check check so Luke
chicks is going Chadli not okay yeah
this is winning actually will g8 and g4
made so he has to take with the bishop
Andrew t1i is still amazingly
uncoordinated here with his pieces the
computer is just giving white a slight
edge so he seems to survive them
no it's better for white but not not
decisive it just what I hate is to give
people very very simple stuff yeah
Quincy to d3 I mean everybody sees that
besides Mia for seconds it was I wanted
to go like Knight to f5 or something
that was one idea of night age forward I
should just play Bishop f3 them of
course the position wasn't any good
before you plate 95 which is just 95 is
just stupid stupid move you can you can
take me to as sort of expected this to
happen and then something like this and
so what I was was planning it's kind of
messy probably better for black am still
the abbot hiscott somewhat bad porn
structure and maybe have some ideas
against this king of like Queen up
something like this but um yeah this is
this is just a bad idea miss placing the
noid and Jaron yeah I just blundered the
game away there with Quincy too okay
thanks for watching